Anyone familiar with the hit series Lucifer
knows that it's chock-full of memorable moments
and scenes.
From a crook who gets caught with his pants
down to a detective turned into a human smoothie,
keep watching to find out about these moments
and more!
Despite season one's darker tone, there is
still some solid humor to be found, with many
solid exchanges and insults.
One of the more entertaining moments is a
glorious exchange between Lucifer and Chloe
in the show's inaugural episode.
Lucifer's extended vacation on earth is interrupted
when a famous friend of his is killed in a
drive-by shooting.
The subsequent police investigation lands
him in the crosshairs of Detective Chloe Decker,
with whom he tries to solve the murder.
Their partnership is, at first, very one-sided
with Lucifer skirting various legalities to
interrogate people, including dangling a rapper
out of a window.
It's after this near act of homicide that
one of the rapper's entourage points out Chloe's
former life as an actor.
Lucifer is quick to jump on this and praise
Chloe's assets in a movie titled "Hot Tub
High School."
"The one with the famous nude scene, coming
out of the hot tub!
It was like a complete "Fast Times" rip-off,
she was like the new Phoebe Cates!"
She quickly asserts her authority by slapping
cuffs on him for his actions, much to Lucifer's
sadistic delight.
With the broader comedic set pieces of later
seasons, it's fun to look back on simpler
exchanges like this one.
It's an early taste of the frequently recurring
dynamic that would make the devil and cop
duo so likable.
We are first shown a taste of Lucifer's backstory
in season one when amidst an investigation
Chloe sees Lucifer's scars.
"Now you can't argue with that, can you?"
It's a low-key but very effective moment where
Lucifer doesn't sugarcoat the actual truth,
stating very bluntly that the scars are leftover
from where he cut off his wings in defiance
of his father.
"Your father did that to you?"
"No!
That's where I cut my wings off.
Well I didn't, Maze did.
I told her to."
Chloe, not yet a believer in Lucifer's demonic
status, doesn't truly grasp the truth behind
his scars.
She looks upon them with what appears to be
genuine shock and legitimate sympathy, and
she quickly stops when Lucifer asks her not
to touch them.
The interactions between Lucifer and Amenadiel
are always a persistent source of drama throughout
the entire series.
Their often strained relationship would grow
from a heated rivalry rife with deceptions
to a healthy and mature familial bond.
During the show's first season we would get
a taste of this kinder relationship in the
episode "Wingman."
Lucifer's prized possession, his wings, had
been stolen and he'd made it his mission to
get them back.
After determining that a piece of divinity
let loose on earth would spell disaster, Amenadiel
begrudgingly agrees to help.
This leads them to an underground auction
where the wings are listed as a high-priced
item, amongst other alleged divine relics.
During the bid for the first item, the chains
of St. Paul, the brothers would share a brief
moment of comradery.
"Paul's wrists were too thick to fit in those
chains."
"I know, that man could never pass up on dessert."
"He should have been the saint of…"
"Honey cakes!"
They not only point them out as fake but take
time to dunk on St. Paul's inability to pass
on dessert, sharing a laugh before resuming
their respectively combative tones.
This is undercut later by the revelation that
Amedadiel played a role in the wing's theft.
However, it's a legitimately sweet moment
and a precursor to the emotional growth both
characters would soon make.
Father Frank was a one-shot character who
definitely left a major impact on Lucifer
and the show's fandom.
In the Season 1 episode "A Priest Walks Into
a Bar," the streetwise priest comes to Lucifer
looking for a favor.
He asks Lucifer to help him with Connor, an
orphaned youth who Frank saw fit to take under
his wing.
Lucifer, being repellent to anyone who serves
his father, is initially callous to Frank.
This would change when Frank, under Lucifer
and Chloe's protection, shares his backstory
as a traveling musician.
Frank's life changed after a car accident
killed not only Connor's parents but Frank's
daughter as well.
After this sobering revelation, Lucifer feels
intrigued by Frank's claim of being a superior
piano player and demands to see him in action.
The duo then engages in a competitive but
friendly piano duet and genuinely seems content
in each other's company.
"Oh!
I think I know what you mean.
Something like that?"
"Yeah!"
Chloe, upon returning, sees the two playing
together and smiles as she sees Lucifer actually
connecting with someone.
This newfound friendship would be cut short
by Frank's untimely death, something that
Lucifer responds to with furious anger.
Despite only making one onscreen appearance,
Frank plays a major role in Lucifer finding
his humanity and growing as a person.
The Season 1 finale of Lucifer definitely
ends the show's story arc with a fittingly
large bang.
Malcolm, a recently resurrected dirty cop,
looks to reclaim his money by holding Trixie,
Chloe's daughter, hostage.
It's a situation made all the direr because
of Lucifer's newfound mortality, something
Malcolm takes full advantage of.
Lucifer attempts to draw on Malcolm's desires,
but the latter reveals that his true desire
is to see Lucifer die.
With a bullet in his stomach, all seems lost
for the former ruler of hell until, in a moment
of desperation, he turns to someone unexpected:
God.
Lucifer makes a plea to his father, that he'll
finally do his bidding if God protects Chloe.
"All that I ask…is that you protect Chloe."
His father hears the message and restores
Lucifer to his full strength.
It's a wonderfully directed moment, only enhanced
by Tom Ellis' performance.
It may be a smaller-scale victory, especially
when compared to the larger multi-character
battles in future finales, but it serves as
the perfect bookend for Season 1 and sets
up intriguing plot developments for Season
2.
Added to the cast in Season 2 is Lucifer's
mother who, after escaping hell, inhabits
the body of the recently deceased Charlotte
Richards.
Upon arriving on Earth, "Charlotte" goes about
making things complicated for Lucifer and
Chloe, and their budding relationship.
From nearly blowing up Chloe with a car bomb,
to almost blasting Linda with her celestial
energy, Charlotte's arrival is marked by rampant
insanity.
One moment that shouldn't be forgotten is
a devious stunt she pulled on the perpetually
gullible Dan Espinoza.
While leaning into her life as Charlotte Richards,
the goddess of creation begins a fling with
the hapless detective, which leads to a very
steamy public kiss in front of several restaurant
patrons, including Amenadiel, her other son.
"Ugh!"
Amenadiel's sorrow is punctuated by a giddy
Maze taking pictures of his reaction.
This moment, as well as their entire love
affair, would, of course, have repercussions
later on for Dan.
Trixie may never get much to do on her own,
but she still has wonderful chemistry with
others.
A sizable amount of Maze's character development
has a lot to do with her relationship with
Trixie, which is similar to that of what an
aunt might have with her niece.
Many of the most riveting scenes of the show
have Trixie somewhere in the crosshairs of
that season's danger.
Anytime we get to see Lucifer interact with
Trixie it is a guaranteed source of charm
and hilarity.
From traumatizing her schoolyard bully with
his devil face to buying her a doll, Lucifer
has certainly given her an interesting childhood.
The swear jar joke, though a remarkably simple
one, always elicits sizable laughs.
Lucifer discovers that Trixie must put money
in a jar for Chloe every time she uses foul
language.
"Swear jar?"
"Oh yes, it's Trixie's."
"You give your child money every time she
swears?!
Oh, bravo detective!"
In response to this revelation, Lucifer tries
to give her a crisp 20 dollar bill to spend
on ample curse words.
Later on, Chloe reprimands him for teaching
Trixie "loophole" curse words to skirt around
the swear jar stipulation.
"Well she called her math homework a cluster-duck,
and her teacher a mother flunker."
It's a hilarious moment and another key factor
in Lucifer's ever-growing appreciation for
humanity.
It would take a long time before Maze would
finally find a partner that could match her
spontaneity and dubious morality.
By the end of the final season, that partner
would reveal themself to be Eve, the first
woman.
However, before Maze was chasing dangerous
bounties into the sunset with Eve, there was
a road not taken.
In Season 3 she would seek a change of pace
to her now very cyclical work-life balance.
In order to shake things up, she opts to chase
a bounty by the name of Ben Rivers to Canada.
Ben quickly proves himself to be just as crafty
as Maze, making for a very playful chase between
them.
Ben eventually explains that his status as
a serial killer is false and that he had been
framed.
Maze agrees to help him and, with the help
of her friends in Los Angeles, is able to
clear his name.
Before he goes off into the night, Ben offers
Maze the opportunity to come with him.
"What if you come with me?
You and me, we're the same.
No roots.
No family."
Maze considers it but ultimately chooses her
life in L.A. over a future with Ben.
Their goodbye is definitely a meaningful moment,
but an important part of her growth.
When Lucifer moved to Netflix for its fourth
year, series creators definitely took advantage
of their newfound lack of restrictions.
After rekindling his relationship with the
free-spirited Eve, Lucifer's regained streak
of debauchery leaks into his life at work.
One notable moment inspired an episode title
after Lucifer wears his, quote, "Orgy Pants
To Work."
For many, one glimpse of Lucifer's rear end
would be enough, but the episode saw fit to
up the ante.
While on the case of a recent victim, Chloe
and Lucifer's investigation leads them to
a nudist colony.
In order to enter they must disrobe, a stipulation
that Chloe protests, but Lucifer and Ella
quickly embrace with gusto.
"Lucifer!"
"Oh, when in Rome detective."
Season 4 is where the show really starts leaning
heavily into its comedic elements, and this
is a prime example of that shift.
It's an underrated, yet hysterical little
moment that showcases the show's vibrant and
often madcap new creative direction.
If Lucifer fans were only allowed to make
a gif out of just one moment from the show,
we'd like to make a case for this one.
When the show's fifth season dropped, the
cast was joined by Statefarm spokesman Dennis
Haysbert as Lucifer's dad, God himself.
God, being all-knowing, already felt familiar
with the show's core characters, including
poor Dan.
Dan, upon realizing just who he is talking
to, starts behaving strangely, to humorous
effect.
"Hey.
Mister, uh, God.
Listen, um, I'm sorry that I slept with your
wife.
I didn't know she was married at the time,
I swear to—"
God at first seems very laid back about the
situation, but then quickly showcases his
true feelings on the matter by exploding Dan
into a human smoothie that paints the walls,
much to Lucifer's shock.
God very quickly reverses the event and puts
Dan back together, but leaves the poor detective
frazzled and traumatized.
A rare show of anger from God during his tenure
as a supporting character, but a morbid and
hilarious one.
It's fair to say that Lucifer leaned heavily
into its comedic elements after the show switched
from FOX to Netflix.
Gone was the darker noir aesthetic of the
early seasons, and in its place were comedy
and bright colors.
The show's final season definitely doubles
down on comedic moments, with one serving
as its ultimate crescendo.
With things amiss in heaven, Lucifer plans
to see what the problem is, but unfortunately,
he can't get his wings to work.
Lucifer also discovers that Linda has been
compiling all her data on him in order to
pen a tell-all book.
The group decides to cull through this data
in order to pinpoint what's going on with
Lucifer's wings, and hilarity naturally ensues.
The most gut-busting moment is Linda's very
direct interpretation of the gang's day-to-day
interactions.
It's a sequence that feels like someone made
a bot watch every episode of the series, then
write a script.
"Crazy that the killer was the first person
we met!"
"What are the chances?"
"I know!"
It's a scene run totally on auto-pilot, with
every character's identifiable or quirky trait
maxed out to eleven, complete with a comically
stock back-and-forth between Lucifer and Chole
and Maze cartoonishly pulling a severed human
head out of a bag.
It's a truly wonderful moment and a hilarious
summation of why fans love these characters
so much.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Lucifer
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.